listen uh I want to keep talking about
the Twitter files I know that many of
you are following the Twitter files and
I also want to make very clear what it
is it's right wing bait that's what it
is it's meant to get people who don't
really know what's going on or who don't
actually read the Twitter files threads
or who simply are looking some for
something to be outraged about
to be outraged and to say we all the
stuff we said was happening was
happening and people need to go to jail
or something bad needs to happen so
let's take a step back we have now seen
at least three releases of the Twitter
files the Twitter files are supposedly
exclusive stories given to Matt taibi
and Bari Weiss to tweet about
exposing
everything that happened at Twitter
and it turns out that really not that
much happened for example we learned
that there was an effort being made in
2020 by the Biden campaign to have
explicit images of Hunter Biden uh
removed from the platform now they were
new to explicit images of Hunter
published without his consent that's not
allowed on Twitter
per their own terms of service and it's
also against the law in Most states to
publish such images and it was framed by
some on the right as the Biden
Administration is censoring content on
Twitter well there was no Biden
administration at the time so cross that
piece off and they're not really
censoring anything they're asking that
content in violation of Twitter's own
policies be removed it wasn't really a
bombshell
[Music]
um
as the Twitter files have continued
coming out more and more clear thinking
individuals have realized what many of
us realized pretty quickly uh Charlie
wurtzel writes about this in the
Atlantic in an article I encourage you
to read called Elon musk's Twitter files
are bait he doesn't actually want
transparency on the social media
platform and this is of course
absolutely correct the Twitter files
expose no crimes that that are clearly
related to the actions Twitter took I'm
going to get to perjury in a second and
I have no interest in hiding anything
from you the emails I get David you're
hiding this and that
I'm just a guy in a room with a
microphone I'm not hiding anything we'll
get to perjury but the Twitter files
expose no crimes with regard to
Twitter's actions and they don't even
expose violations of Twitter's own terms
of service Twitter's own terms of
service if you want to read them include
a process for uh communicating content
that content is violating Twitter's uh
terms of service it includes these very
general catch-alls that these social
media platforms can at the end of the
day decide to moderate content however
the hell they want as long as they're
not doing something like saying we don't
allow Christians to post that would be
against the law
but beyond that all of these platforms
can do this and it's in their terms of
service now you can say you disagree
with it okay but it's in their terms of
service so the point here is the Twitter
files expose no crimes and no violations
of Twitter's own terms of service they
are intended to play
to the right wing persecution complex
we're being censored we're being
silenced we're not allowed to give the
alternative perspectives on covid or on
drinking urine neuron whatever it is
that they want to do when private
businesses tell you here's what we're
doing in our terms of service and you
accept and then they do it there isn't
very much to talk about at worst what
we're learning is something we knew
which is Twitter does what Fox News does
right if you want to accept the most
heavy argument that could be made which
I don't believe is actually defensible
based on video but it would be Twitter
is crafting a partisan measure a message
in through their moderation and
decisions well that's what Fox News does
the difference being Twitter is a
platform on which everybody gets to post
at least in principle Fox News is
broadcasting out one way no connection
between the Biden campaign and the
suspension of Donald Trump on Twitter
which was a big thing that they had
their their hopes very high for the most
interesting part out of all of this to
me
is the part of the files that say the
Trump Administration not campaign
apparently had the exact type of access
to Twitter moderation meaning they had
email addresses they could email so part
of the controversy is that the Biden
campaign rather than
reporting tweets the way you and I have
to had email addresses of people at
Twitter that they could email and say
hey take a look at this take a look at
that you could argue that that's wrong
you could argue the Biden campaign
should have had to use the same system
we all have to use to report tweets fine
but the Twitter files also say that the
Trump
administration had the very same email
access
conservatives are silent about that part
okay
let's now talk about maybe maybe the one
part that maybe is something and you
know I'm getting emails from people
saying David you won't talk about this
listen up folks Buckle in because I'm
talking about it the one thing I can
maybe find that that would be under the
route the the umbrella of what we would
call Criminal
is that there are now allegations that
Jack Dorsey perjured himself former CEO
of Twitter one of the instrumental early
people Jack Dorsey said to Congress
under oath Twitter isn't Shadow Banning
people
according to the Twitter files Twitter
was Shadow Banning people and that thus
that is perjury because Jack lied under
oath let's take a look at the clip from
that hearing years ago I want to read a
few quotes about Twitter's practices and
I just want you to tell me if they're
true or not please uh social media is
being rigged to censor conservatives is
that true of Twitter no
I don't know what Twitter is up to it
sure looks like to me that they're
censoring people and they ought to stop
it are you censoring people no
Twitter Shadow Banning prominent
Republicans
bad is that true no okay so Jack Dorsey
said we are not Shadow Banning people
and it appears based on some of the
stuff that's been removed released that
that Twitter was so listen very
carefully here
if Jack Dorsey perjured himself
and you can prove it throw the book at
him prosecute him do it I don't care if
you can prove that the shadow band
screenshots released in the Twitter
files are real
and that Jack Dorsey knew that there was
Shadow Banning going on when he
testified right because that's part of
it perjury did you know that you were
telling a lie if you can prove those two
points then go ahead and prosecute him
I do want to remind you however
Republicans spent three years during the
Mueller probe saying lying to Congress
and lying to the FBI that's all you can
get what about the underlying crimes
what about the collusion with Russia
what about this that or the other thing
Financial crimes all you've got is lying
under oath that's the only thing that's
politically targeted those Pro when all
you have is lying those are politically
targeted prosecutions of trump people we
shouldn't even be worried about that
well
if you were saying that during the
Mueller probe then maybe you should be
saying the same thing here
notice I'm not saying that I'm saying if
he perjured himself go after him it
doesn't relate to the type of
criminality that they've been alleging
Twitter engaged in this is just a guy
who maybe lied go after him for it but
by all means but remember that you all
were the ones saying during the Mueller
probe when all you've got is lying you
know you've really got nothing
when you're looking for a good
documentary to watch you scroll through
Netflix and Hulu for a while there
aren't that many you realize you've seen
the good ones what if I told you there's
a streaming platform exclusively for
documentaries with the best selection
where you won't run out of top quality
documentaries that is curiosity stream
with a massive catalog of the newest and
best documentaries classic titles from
years ago exclusive content you can't
find anywhere else I just watched
Pompeii disaster Street I visited
Pompeii in Italy before I wish I had
seen the documentary before visiting
because it was made very clear I missed
a lot when I actually went to Pompeii
you can watch curiositystream on all of
your devices they're always adding new
titles politics philosophy True Crime
nature they have everything and my
audience gets curiosity stream for under
two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below